ah alright we are live for another
YouTube hang out my last one of the day
it's been a crazy day today I'm joined
by farbod I met him at an event in
Toronto that was around mentorship and
he came up afterwards and said hey I
want I want to connect the one I want to
pick your brain a little more so here we
are and welcome aboard far by thanks I'm
happy to be here very excited actually
I'm pretty excited so a little a quick
story so I went to this event with the
mayor of the city and two or three other
panelists and we talked about mentorship
and then of course afterwards you know
everybody rushes to me see will you be
my mentor will you help me and and for
those of you who are looking to get
mentored by someone or look to get some
advice from someone ah the thing that
mentors hate is not following up not
following through like somebody gives
you advice you don't do the work and so
I always have a process that i go
through because i like helping people
who are committed to making themselves
better but I hate investing time when
somebody doesn't do anything you know
I'm value my time and I want to see
people taking action and changing the
life as a result and so everybody who
came up to me I don't know 20 30th and
people came up to be asking for
basically the same thing I all I gave
everybody at the same process to say hey
look up my email address is on my
website go find me and shoot me an email
of that like less than half the people
actually did it and then I said send an
email to my assistant I'm going to give
the email address and and she'll set
something up and then of that most
people didn't do it and so from the 20
or 30 people only two people actually
followed through and we had one a couple
weeks ago and here's far by this number
two and so just a lesson like just
follow up right it's it's not i'm not
asking that you're asking for my time
right which I value a lot I'm not asking
a lot from you I'm asking you to spend
five minutes going to my website find a
my email and then shoot an email to my
assistant who I gave you the address for
and figure out of meeting times like 10
minutes of investment that most people
just don't follow through on and that's
why being a mentor sucks for a lot of
people and that's why this
as long as while a lot of people say no
because it's hard for them they think
lump they love farbod in with the 29 of
the people who didn't follow through
yeah so anyway can for big ups to you
congrats and falling through and here we
are so we got some time to talk about
you and help you with that what you're
going through so yeah what's up how can
I help well I'm actually I'm actually
guilty of that I've actually lost one
mentor because he would have me do
exercises and and we would meet two
weeks from that meeting and he would say
hi for but so did you do what I asked
you to do what I said I forgot and he
would say no okay and then that happened
a few times and eventually he is stopped
talking to me and i took that lesson not
every time i talk to people i make sure
that i thought i'm very persistent and I
and I see it as a responsibility because
they give me their time and I want to
show them that I value at time so that's
that's that's what I do and a little bit
about myself i'm actually a fourth-year
mechanical engineering student at
Ryerson i'm also a big advocate for for
self for self-development and and
self-mastery because when i was 12 years
old you know mud by parents got divorced
and that definitely took a huge toll on
you know on how i looked at things even
though they were very supportive and
loving and then i started a I senator
company and Here I am today and so let's
talk how can I help what's going on well
here's the thing you and I talked about
I showed you a list of books that I want
to read they were about their also hope
books you know how to make friends and
influence other bar del karnegi the 7
habits of highly effective people you
looked at the list and you told me this
day like I had like 40 items on it and
you looked at it this is ash Restless if
anything and I said why I said there's
just so much material and I and I agree
with you so I guess for someone that is
starting out on this path on the path of
self-development you know really they
start what should be their first step
towards bettering themselves becoming a
better version of themselves so this I
think a lot of people get stuck on this
because there is no first step there's
no one like perfect step that you have
to take apart from getting started
because a lot of people just make a list
and they get so stressed out about the
first step that they never actually do
anything where that's the biggest
mistake of all the first step is to
actually just get started and and and
quit on things that don't make sense to
you so you know you have your list of 40
books if that's where you want to start
great read the first chapter of the
first look you don't have to finish the
book if it's not meaningful to you like
if you're having a hard time reading for
the book it's not sinking it's not
resonating with you know maybe in five
years it'll resonate maybe in five years
will be something in there you can pull
or maybe never maybe just that author
didn't stick with you whatever just
because I million other people like feel
Carnegie maybe Dale Carnegie just
doesn't speak too far by that it's
awesome but don't like force yourself to
read through an entire book uh just like
you know if you watch my youtube channel
maybe my youtube channel helps you when
you get inspired maybe somebody watches
videos not really for me cool like don't
sit there watching hours of videos
because somebody else told you was great
if you don't feel it then stop and so I
think a lot of people don't have the
courage to start and a lot of people
don't have the courage to stop when it's
not working so having the list is great
I you know one of the things that I
would do is when when I was reading a
book that I really enjoyed and they
mentioned somebody else's book then I
would take note like oh that you know
this person I really enjoy likes this
book so I'm going to go check that out
or somebody that I'm interviewing on
YouTube that I respect says hey I really
like this channel let go I'll make a
list like oh I'll go check that out and
I'll watch one video or two videos and
make a decision like oh this is really
cool and subscribe burning like greater
work for that person just doesn't work
for me like I don't want to keep filling
my head with things just because
somebody else told me that it was a good
thing to do so it's a good for cell
phone absolutely do you need to fill
your head absolutely our books too
to do it it can be our videos the way to
do it like I prefer video two books but
that's me whatever like maybe you you
love to read and you're sitting on the
subway and that's how you you'd rather
see the printed word and that's how you
digest the information great maybe we
need to go to events like maybe seeing
somebody live makes a big difference for
you versus just watching them on video
whatever your learning style is as soon
as you understand it that's going to
really rapidly escalate how quickly you
can learn and then once you decide your
learning style then within that learning
style books or videos or seminars
whatever just grow and try see so you
see what makes you come alive see what
you love I listened to tons of different
you know business experts who have
YouTube channels and most of them I
don't resonate with their a couple that
whose channels that like to subscribe to
and I watch their videos and it gives me
some things to think about but I'll give
lots of people a chance you know like
less people give me a chance and and
maybe they liked the video and they
subscribe for means like I'm not sure
how to watch some more and and maybe
they're like who is this guy I don't
like this guy you know he's talking
nonsense that's a great you know you'll
find somebody else it's awesome so it's
just starting like take that list and
start and read the first chocolate don't
even buy the book yet go to the
bookstore open up the book either at the
start or random page and see if the
message on there is interesting for you
spend 10 minutes reading and see does it
do you like it right and if you do then
pick up the book and take it home and
buy and if you don't just start crossing
up the list right yeah that's it that's
a great point and you know going off
your uh what you just mentioned I think
one of the reasons uh people don't want
to take the first step is because well
first of all they look at others and
they look at you know how far they are
they for they are they are into the into
the whole self development game and and
just scary right and and so do for me I
look at that but but I recognize it and
I and I and I do it anyways and i love
you mention you i started by reading the
first chapter and then the second
chapter I've I started reading this
audio books but then what I realized was
is I'm not being honest with myself so
there was a point about a year ago where
you know I looked at myself in the
mirror and I said hey for what you know
I love you um yeah I i but but you know
what I think 10 years from now you're
going to look back and you're gonna and
you're going to hit yourself and I and I
thought about it and and and I said do I
want to spend my time thinking about
that girl that didn't takes me back
right or do i do I want to work on
myself do I want to work on the company
right so I said far but you're lazy you
just get off your butt start doing
things right and then I mean I realize
also have a little bit of ego you know I
don't want to read a book because I
really think that I know everything
which is not true I don't want anything
like and there are things that I don't
know that I don't know um so you know
and I realized oh I'm gonna negative I
gotta change my vision so once that I
started looking at myself questioning
myself i think is when i started picking
up the first book and angry and and i'm
making slow progress every time you know
honestly I'm so honest with with myself
at times that it hurts are you know I I
sometimes I'm harsh on myself a little
bit and and some people might say you
know you gotta like yourself love
yourself before you love it widows and
that's true but I feel like there is a
fine line between the two you need to be
honest with yourself you know when I'm
at home watching a YouTube video I need
to realize what is it that I could do
that would make a more impact you know
on my life on other people than just
watching a cat video on youtube sure I
think in terms of being lazy i don't
believe people are lazy i think you just
have goals that don't inspire them you
haven't figured out what you want to do
where there's been times you you call
yourself ladies this one time so you've
you've busted like you've gone crazy
working you you are up till you know
three in the morning cranking something
out because you were just as fired by it
right so like i don't think people are
naturally lazy just you gotta have
something that you
work for you have something you want to
live for and so it's identifying that
and as much as you can design your life
and career around that you're gonna
you're going to be more motivated to go
out and do it well if you're being
forced it like you're in some crappy job
that I would be lazy man I don't want to
work for some crappy you know compania
doesn't respect what I'm doing and I'm
doing work way beneath me like I get why
people work nine to five and then live
for the evenings and weekends but if
you're doing something that you love and
you're passionate about that that should
be a driving force for you and if you're
if you find yourself getting lazy then
it's thinking okay look I got to set
bigger goals I got to do something more
important to me and turns up knowing
everything I think that the you see that
executes right like you could watch a
Steve Jobs video and repeat what he said
line by line and feel like you know what
he's saying but but what have you done
like you got to go and do what he's
saying to actually feel it and so saying
that like oh I've heard it all before
it's the same thing again and again and
again well maybe you should stop listen
like stop reading so many books like
read one book a month and then spend the
rest of the time doing right you know
YouTube's goal is to keep people on
YouTube for as long as possible that's
that's their algorithm that's how they
make money and I get it I don't want
people on YouTube all day like I'd
rather you watch one of my videos a
month and be out killing it because you
took action on it than just watching
every single video i put out if you need
that if that helps you that's great but
i don't want you living on youtube I
want you out executed I want you out
building a business and building
building a better life for yourself and
so it's easy to it's easy for people to
think not just you it's easy people to
think I already know that okay so why
are you what have you done anything
about it like you know you're gonna hear
the same thing in the next video in the
next book but you gotta go and execute
to actually know it yeah that's that's
that's very true and you know that's uh
I started realizing i'm spending so much
time reading books and and and watching
youtube videos i probably watch your top
10 videos and and they are inspiring and
I and I feel great but you know when
I go on autopilot I I don't think about
that I stop I stop thinking about what
I've learned and I think you know that's
when I i was reading there's a highly
the 7 Habits of Highly Effective People
and in a listen first or second chapter
it was said that you need to sort of
look and imagine your ray your name on
it on a on a gravestone I can anymore
your way backwards and and this might
sound a little creepy but i live in
intron in the north north korea there is
a cemetery right around a quarter nice
that's so what i do every once in a
while you know I I take a walk and I and
I look at all the people and and I look
at all the gravestones that I and I
actually do imagine myself it's not
depressing it's not sad it's it's being
realistic and and I say okay you know
what is it that I want that too to have
done when I when I'm no longer around
but I'm but I'm dead you know and and
you know that's that's sort of that's
one of the few practical things that I
do that put some like I said some people
think it's creepy but hey um it that's
that's that's if that that's what I want
to do that's what I want to do in and I
don't suggest it for everybody but okay
yeah I think breaking free of autopilot
mode is not just doing that every once
in a while or some random time when you
think about it you need to schedule it
in like bright whether that whether
that's the thing that makes you start
thinking about living a more important
life then do that every day that's part
of your like you need a morning routine
that set you up for success whatever
that means whether that's watching the
video reading the passage and above
reviewing passages that you read before
that really meant something to you
walking through the North your graveyard
and imagining yourself like schedule
something in every day so that you are
inspired and you are motivated and
you're not just going on autopilot mode
because I bet the days when you go in
autopilot if you look at what you did in
the morning it was probably pretty
mediocre yeah we weren't doing anything
inspiring so
don't let life happen you by accident
planet and it starts with setting up the
morning routine that works for you
that's oh my god I can't agree with that
more you know I think I want auto pilot
fifty percent at a time and that is a
high number but i think that's that's
where i'm at because I I notice it that
i noticed i watch a YouTube video I
unpractical I write down one thing that
I've learned from that video and I
suggest whoever is watching this video
just don't let don't try to apply
whatever we say to your life just take
down one thing and do that one thing and
and that's what I do but there are times
where you know that that constant
dollars in my face I might remind my
head right in my constantly remind
myself that I need to better myself
stops and it stops and I go on autopilot
and and so what what I started doing was
you know I just kept up I just kept
reading reading reading books are really
in south bay at work we're watching it
to you to youtube videos are listening
to people i have three mentors and but
again if you take all of this and don't
actually sit it doesn't matter like six
years ago people didn't know that
smoking cigarettes was that you know now
we know smoking cigars is bad we know it
causes cancer but we still do it you
know it's like we need in a great area
where there is so much information with
so little action and I one of them but I
at least like I know that I am and anime
and I tried and I try to actualize I I
try to put I thought you said schedule
it in it put it in my google calendar
and and it's it's it's helped me the
book but you gotta do it consistently
yes right like tomorrow morning you got
to wake up and do it and the next day do
it again and whether it's Google
Calendar or without like the tools don't
matter you got to lose everybody's
looking for the next productivity tool
and how about tools the tools are there
you do it right but so you know you're
you need to create if you're doing good
morning routine that's a great start
right every day
that should that should take you at
least through a good chunk of the day
feeling like you're motivated and
inspired and you're working hard to your
abilities are not going on a pilot mode
if you find that like two o'clock comes
and you start drifting off then you need
to fix the rest of your environment
right like the morning chunk like like
the caffeine hit last for a certain
amount of time and then it dies down
what else you're gonna do right what is
your what is your work environment like
look at my working environment I come in
here I got this big eyes picture Steve
Jobs look in my face right I were
telling how my parents ap Jenny people
who inspire me this is here for a reason
right like I'm sitting here I see the
scene Tyler straight down there and then
I have I look over here I got jobs
looking at me uh you know it's kind of
hard to slack off when I walk in here
and I got this happening right so
whatever it is for you like what's in
your environment whether it's a just
have to cost a lot right it could be a
quote you put on the wall or whatever
just you need to design an environment
because the people around you are
keeping you like your environment right
now and the people around you are
keeping you where you are yes so you
need to change that and it's part of the
change your friends and the people
that's a process but changing your
environments all these you're changing
your schedule is a lot easier and I was
done within with intent so you know
you're a student you know I'm assuming
you work from home or if you have a
doorman whatever like here's an example
I move into my new place and I'm talking
with my wife about my closet because I
have a you know get a closet to myself
which is great she gets two closets I
get one closet you know how it goes and
I said I want my I want my closet to be
inspiring I want to walk into my closet
and feel inspired how do I do that that
seemed like everything around me needs
to build me up to be a better version of
me and so when I was arranging how I put
something my clouds and arranging where
things go in a range and we know what
I'm gonna add in there that's seen 10
and most people think it's just a closet
but if I walk into my closet if I want
to walk into my washroom if I walk into
my office I want to feel inspired to do
more
be greater yes and so like what is your
environment look like doesn't have to
you don't have to go out and buy some
fancy expensive thing you know these
pictures in cost a lot to create and put
up but but it's now designed with intent
this your living room inspire you you
know does your bedroom inspire you you
know this your blanket inspired whatever
right I know if you find yourself
falling off like maybe a two o'clock you
need another hit maybe you go and you
just remind yourself of a passage from a
book or you spend 20 minutes over lunch
reading you know whatever it is um
whatever you need to do for you right
this is for me you know I have my
morning routine and then I have an
environment that supports me that that's
good like I don't need anything else for
the day I'm ready to go but but for
those you watching like Fargo
difficulties watching to whatever maybe
need more maybe you need it twelve
o'clock like quick refresher maybe need
a five o'clock you know like when you're
getting tired another quick quote or
maybe once a video once a book whatever
like experiment there's no there's no
perfect answer just a perfect answer for
you and that may evolve and change it
can may find hey you know what I don't
need that twelve o'clock hit anymore I'm
good now right just everything around
you is keeping you where you are and
until you change it and you have the
ability to change it it's all within
your control stop living life by
accident and just accepting what's
around you and design everything with
intent and purpose that's right I you
drop so many older nuggets um and I
can't agree with you more I some of the
things that are you all give a few
examples so there is an app called the
instance and what the app does is keeps
track of all the time you spend on your
phone automatically all you have to do
is download it and you're not pay me for
this this is not I don't even know them
but I am like I downloaded the app it's
two months ago and I I speak at
different events to especially to
first-year engineering students so I had
one of the classes download the app and
and writing for them so the entire class
download idea and I said okay put your
hands up if you think you're spending
less than two hours or three hours on
your phone per day and yeah everyone
thought you know there is swelling
around of two hours three hours to UM
some rounded area and and that's not
true because what happened was they came
back the week after and I looked at
their on there I said some would someone
like to volunteer to show me their the
results they're at their usage and this
person was nice enough to come up on
this stage and he shared it with
everybody and he was around five hours
turns around everyone in that house in
that class is log in and around four to
five hours of a mobile phone usage so
what I'm getting at is we don't have the
awareness to know how much time you're
spending on doing things that don't
matter so this instant app it has also a
[ __ ] so I get it and it's right on my
phone I see it there are times where I
spanks you know not now about before I
used to spend six hours on my foot
that's crazy you know so that's bringing
awareness to to my daily habits the
other thing that I thought I that I do
is you know I print I write down three
tacos SMART goals they need to be smart
and I you can help me with what smart
stands for but I write them down i print
and my turn around the house but around
around my place and I look at it every
day but honestly there are still times
that I thought and you know that this is
why I'm here this is what I'm talking to
you because you understand it you know I
am still struggling with are constantly
being on you know my top game and and
you know that sometimes stops but at
least you know I'm honest I'm practical
and I want to make things happen so
what's your why though like for your
business or what why why are you doing
this why you want to be an entrepreneur
well I the first of all I you know I I
just
I i love i love the game you know i love
i love losing I not didn't reject it I
love winning and but one of the many
that one of main raises I just feel a
sense of responsibility towards people
especially my parents who have helped me
to get where I am today you know and
that's just that's just how I feel it
might be an external factor for me or
external push but you know that's one
otherwise but I also really really
really like starting something that is
bigger than Who I am you know I I want
to start something that that doesn't
that doesn't stop with with my thoughts
with my actions I wanted to reach more
people I want to help more people and
that's why that's why I started a
company also i love selling i love
selling so much yeah but all that's not
enough yet right because you're still
slacking right like when I'm in the
sulfur I don't use the phone really much
so I don't I don't need that app but
some people are asking about it um and
you know this two men when you're
working hard on something when you're
like grinding something now because
you're sewing is you're not paying
attention to your phone and all the
distractions are on there like you don't
need that you know you're not working
hard you don't need the apt to say I'm
not worried no you're not working hard
you know you're slacking so like so like
the why isn't strong enough yet like the
work that you're doing if that's if
that's what you if that really is what
drives you motivates you to give back in
to do something bigger than you and to
make your parents proud or whatever it
is then you haven't figured out how to
do it yet like the work of you doing you
must feel isn't helping you get there
yet like whatever you started with your
business or your career path or whatever
isn't helping you fulfill those higher
purpose goals because if you were
feeling that master satisfaction then
you wouldn't be massive distractive
everything else is going on yes I know I
agree and this is why I'm seeking
seeking help you know I'm greeting I'm
reading books because I do realize there
are things that are lacking and I and I
do I have mental exercises that I do
like every night I look at what are the
three things that went well
um in the day you know I write down what
is it that I achieved today and what is
it that I want to achieve by the end
next week in terms of creating something
in me that is always in me and firing
meal I feel like I know what it is but I
haven't been able to pin it down and and
and i feel like i'm close and but hey um
um um here's the thing you need to
figure out like right now you're seeing
the world through your eyes like I love
selling I want to feel good because my
parents recognize me I wanted to
something bigger than myself where the
real motivation comes from helping
somebody else like what can farbod give
that can help humanity so now what's
your gift what are you going to work on
that good I gotta submit when I when I'm
helping somebody else out like that
fuels me it lifts my spirits much more
than I made an extra X amount of dollars
today yeah so instead of being like the
internal focus can be good as a starting
point but then you're constantly trying
to jumpstart your motivation constant
trying to prime it where if you're
motivated by something greater like what
can you do I maybe you don't know yet
that's fine it's fair like maybe you
don't have that answer yet but that's if
I were you that's where I would try to
figure it out like what's my big why
that is outwardly focused that helps
other people through the body that i can
create for them and maybe ceiling to get
better and you got to learn and you know
maybe you can't provide that insane
value yet maybe you can I don't know but
what is that external like how are you
going to be giving people value and when
you start feeling that when you're
motivated by waking up every day and
helping others that that's that's a drug
that you don't need a lot of the other
stuff but I feel like that's missing
from what you're talking about in what
you're doing with your career and your
business right now well i mean the the
way I've I expected it may have sounded
made it sound like that and
and that's right i mean there's those
things that I struggle with but you know
I really I really really enjoyed helping
someone especially through things that
are practical you know I I talked to
first-year engineering students all the
time all the time because I understand
their struggles um I know how tough some
of them have it and and you know we hold
what I'm a mentor at Ryerson to and what
I do is I we sit down for half an hour
45 minutes and and at the end of that
session when when we are done with the
when you're done I really feel I really
feel good and also every time I help
someone when I know someone has used
their services my company our company
provides it also it it also is is a very
satisfying feeling for me and and yes I
love helping people I just you know I
don't know how to explain it but I there
are still times that I fell off I i want
it i want to be operating at my maximum
effort like at all times and that's the
issue that i have on I feel like
sometimes I'm too harsh on myself oh
sure I but it's not sometimes you fall
off is like half the time you're you're
coasting you're on autopilot that's not
that's not some time you trying to do a
lot to keep you motivated inspired and
excited where it's like the work like
you know I want to get a million
subscribers on my youtube channel it's
one of my goals right it's a goal right
it's smart i want to get it by this date
whatever right we're coming up on four
hundred thousand that's a great goal to
have but i love the work of what i'm
doing like i loved making YouTube videos
i love being a part of the community of
love ancient what I love doing this like
I'm not getting paid to do this I love
because I want to help you I want to
help the people who are the same problem
the situation you're going through and
hopefully inspires them to do something
I love the work i love the process not
just chasing some goal the goal is
motivating sure it's like it's a good
benchmark milestone but if all you do is
chase the goal
then you're going to do things that you
don't like I could get two million views
million subscribers faster by doing
other things right I go get there faster
the way I'm taking it though I enjoy the
process of what I'm doing so the goal
isn't as important as as the work so
like your work should fuel you everybody
likes helping people like that that's
it's it's the human condition we like
feeling like we're valuable to others so
what's the what's the lens that you see
the world through that you can help like
for me it's entrepreneurship I can help
people through entrepreneurship to what
I've learned and what I've done what I
studied I can help others through that
you know I would love to help somebody
learn Spanish but I don't speak Spanish
I don't want to learn Spanish you know
so the process yes you love helping
people you love helping engineering
students you love helping your customers
like what's the what's the work that you
love that you can't wait to go back and
do before this I was I was reviewing the
videos to go a lot like I still watch
every video that goes up on the channel
i'm still reviewing i have a team of six
people who work just on a YouTube
channel but I still want to see
everything that goes up like for me I
love it I look forward to it i try to
chunk out time to make that happen so
you got to enjoy the work right so not
just the result of the helping people
like the process right I don't know you
found that yet like if it's helping
engineering students and can you can you
make that into a business and just try
to do that all day long and turn that
into something that you can turn a
career out of if it's your your company
you know you are you provide enough
value dude do you enjoy everyday the
section you're taking right I mean not
every day is amazing a beautiful roses
and right there's a lot of crap you have
to deal with us an entrepreneur but net
net you should you shouldn't like the
thing that gets you through the crap is
the love of the work but like you do it
because you want to do it yeah and
getting paid is a nice side bonus let me
do it to do it right so I never agreed
with you and you know since we started a
company two years ago we've raised over
165,000 dollars
and I'll tell you we haven't paid
ourselves people in Paris or five
hundred dollars of that entire money and
and like you said I loved it so much I
enough I love the work so much but again
um I feel like even when I'm working
when I'm on my computer writing an email
to a customer or or or a partner I'm
still an autopilot like I I I hate I
hate losing consciousness I want to be
able to uh you know always be on top of
everything that I do and I and that's
gonna that's been a problem for me
because there are times where I work a
hundred hours per week but I still don't
think that it wasn't that it wasn't that
wasn't good enough right and that's
that's an issue that I deal with yeah
and it's not about that it's not about
the quantity of hours it's yeah how
engaged you are in those hours right
yeah and you're young and your student
you're not marrying off kids you know
like your parents are still healthy
right like you don't have other things
you may not be able to work 100 hours
you know when you get older and have
other responsibilities but a hundred
hours just on autopilot like you need to
connect more deeply with the work that
you're doing and even maybe that's just
a tweak maybe that's like hey guys you
know you've co-founders in your business
yeah baby hey guys like I love what
we're doing here is what i love most
about the business i want to focus on
this right like the fact you raise money
having paint yourself yet like you
haven't hit your business model yet you
may have to change your business model
before it takes off right you mean pivot
couple times before the thing goes and
flies so it's going to happen it's like
the way your business going to take off
and you're going to make a lot of money
and have a big impact and help a lot of
people is when you're spending your time
as engaged as possible and your partners
to like the work that you're doing
you're not just coasting yeah you're
grinding it out and put in the hours but
you're engaged like you love what you're
doing you love writing that email to
that customer or following up on the
phone or you know if you're the sales
guy whatever else that you're doing you
get great meaning and value from that
process and it sounds like there's still
a disconnect in what you're doing so
it's either the work within the business
that you have has to change or maybe the
company has to change like maybe the
product you're selling you just you
should saw an opportunity and you chased
it instead of like I need to make this
this is a deep passion of mine I'm going
to will it into existence it's going to
happen because I say it's going to
happen um it's a totally different thing
right if it's just hey here's a here's a
chance to make some money this is a hot
opportunity let's go there but like it's
hard it's hard like you can pull the ink
magazine top 100 hottest businesses the
start and i can say i'm going to go do
that i'm not going to be super
passionate about that like as much as I
love helping customers if it's you you
know the hottest industry is trucking
you know I don't want to get into
trucking right remember like I no matter
how much i love servicing my customers
and delivering my goods on time and all
of this stuff nothing against the
trucker's that are watching the show
it's just not for me I don't want to do
this I'm going to be constantly trying
to motivate myself to get up every day
and do the work because I don't enjoy
the work right so it sounds like for me
you need to you need to connect better
with the work that you're doing and that
may mean totally change in the direction
your business or maybe there's a way
that you can make you work within but
you know you have the ability to be
Michael Jordan level talent at something
right but you're not now right and you
have the tools and the energy and the
drive and the research to be able to go
and do it but the work that you're doing
like like you're Michael Jordan trying
to be a football player or trying to be
a baseball player right like that's what
you're doing you're hustling Michael
John was the first guy up every day to
get to the baseball field and take
batting practice and try to play and he
just eat it just wasn't his thing when
he went back a basketball and he rocked
it so like stop trying to play baseball
right do basketball yeah that's by yeah
and I think you're you're you're right
um it's I gotta find the reason and I'm
and I'm I'm looking every day I'm
searching for every day the company is
doing well uh it's looks like to avoid
we paid yourself well it's because we
are putting back we want to put back
whatever we get into the company like we
have other means of making money
different things
right now we just started like starting
a month from now we are going to start
paying ourselves and the idea behind
behind the company is is it is a battery
rental service if we place kiosks around
the city that this spends fully charged
and 4G naval power packs or portable
phone chargers for rent or purchase
right so it is about helping people like
for example I was down downtown and I
see a ton of people playing pokemon go
and do they all have their phones the
power pack attached to it so you know
what I do I short with one of our kiosks
and I place it there and it's got around
50 power packs in it they all come
within the first hour of deployment of
that kiosk all the power packs were gone
right but i think it's it's something
internal and and i and i love talking to
you i love talking to listen to not
watch your videos because every time I'm
listening I'm learning I'm absorbing
things I feel like it's clearing the
picture of what I want to do in the
future a little bit more and and every
time I do it it goes straight back to
the company now I've been able to know
okay why is it that I progress in it and
what is the reason behind it but now I
don't now I spent that time that I don't
procrastinate it in progress in it and
put it into the company and but I I
think it's for me it's a little internal
and yeah yeah I mean a couple things why
not and I get this is a public thing and
you know people watch and all that stuff
but you know you got it if it were me
and I haven't made myself I would be I
would be pissed that my company is not
doing well right like I wouldn't be
saying my company's doing well like
we're growing we're trying to do better
but anybody who comes in like you know
just I just acquired a company a salsa
dancing company here in North York and
any of the instructors who think that
they're great it's like you are not
great like you might be really good but
you kids like if you think you're doing
well means there's no improvement right
you think you're great like there's
still a lot of work that you need to do
and if i'm not paying myself something
needs to be done a lot better uh it's
great that you can show
up and the business model can work like
you can make money in any industry right
you can make money in truck and you can
make money in printing posters right you
can make money and tons of different
things so it's not the company idea
doesn't matter like it great the choke
with Pokemon going and help there's a
lot of different ways to make that
business work it's more are you like are
you passionate about batteries like yeah
are you like I'm not usually like that
will usually come from a deeper
reflection of you where it's I love
reliability right like I want to be the
guy that people rely on for help right
let's finding your one word for me it's
believed you should come from your
parents maybe the fact your parents
weren't together you know you weren't
connected as well whatever it is like if
we're liabilities your thing you want
people to rely on you then it than that
that's one extension like batteries
right great this is your reliable source
we're here for you and you get comfort
knowing that people are counting on you
and improving their days because of it
but there has to be a deep thing not
just something that you tell yourself
because you can make customers happy in
any industry you can have you can have
success in any you want to you want to
do you know Smurf clothing you can make
money at it like this you can have money
anywhere right it's just it's going to
come from a place where you are getting
insane value from the process of doing
it right like you feel like you're truly
serving the world not just fulfilling a
market need mm-hmm right yeah notice
that the company is sorted out of it out
of an personal need but I I know where
you're coming from and you know I will
take and whatever you said today and I
will take a second look you know what is
it that I I feel disconnected oh you
know why do you value most what's your
number what's your number one core value
my number one core value is too and
obviously this is going to sound cliché
but it is it is to know that when I've
made a connection with someone
I've been able to leave something on the
table for them you know that's that's
that's how I that's what my values is
it's really you know again like helping
because I've received I've been in some
bad places and I've received I've
received a ton of health where I didn't
think they would help me I really didn't
think that if I knock on someone's door
and ask for the help um you know they
would say yes and they did so you know
that water what I've been doing through
the company and I my speaking events I
go to is is I just want I just want to
give other people value and that's
that's my thing so if helping people and
connection is the biggest is what you
value most if that's what gets you super
excited then you're not doing enough of
that in the process of your business
like the day-to-day work 100 hours a
week you're spending there's not enough
connection to other people in that work
so your auto piloting because you don't
you don't feel the connection oh [ __ ] so
as if everyone for me it's not like I
like helping people for me is to believe
but you know connection is great so if
that's you then you got to figure out
the to put that more into your
day-to-day tasks and frame it in a way
that helps your business grow mmhmm yeah
yes I totally agree and the that way you
get excited about your work like if it's
going out you love speaking and you love
coaching people one-on-one and you love
given advice and feedback and you really
vibe off of that then set yourself up
for that like what industry events can
you speak at or where can you go out and
help partners connect to each other
right like more of your work just has to
be around the stuff that really at a
deep level meeting something important
to you then using attend be like I'm so
like I get to go today and I got to meet
all these people i'm gonna i'm going to
leave as much on the table for them as
possible like you won't be tracking your
phone and all the crap that you're doing
in there because you're out doing the
stuff that you love right well I mean
that's that's true but at the same time
I look at the people that in my
and how much time you know they're
racing doing things that don't really
matter in and contribute to their life
and you know there are some words that
are doing a word but there are some was
that or not and and I just want to help
them you know be more aware of why is it
that the erase wasting time but going
back to be more connected with people
and helping more people it's funny
because when we first started the
company year and a half ago I went out
in an x and I surveyed a thousand people
I'd literally me and my team survey
close to a thousand people and ask him
if the better they thought it was a good
idea or not and every time I didn't I
thought I felt a little better because I
was able to talk to someone share the
idea with someone else and I feel like
I've stopped doing that I'm now so
focused on creating the company on
focusing the accounting the taxes and
and and doing things that are not
putting me out there so I feel like I
need to be doing a little bit of bit of
more of that and put myself out and get
in front of people and talk work here's
a good exercise I mean I already feel
like you're you're you have a bit of a
better plan on how to how to move
forward with this but a good exercise
that I would look at for you is you're
already self-aware enough in some
moments to recognize that you're on
autopilot mode which is great because a
lot of people don't they just they just
coast right and it's hard to catch
yourself in the moment to say you know
what I I'm like sucking right now I'm
not doing anything really valuable if
you can catch yourself in those moments
then i would i would start looking at
what activities are you doing if you
keep a journal or whatever again the
tools don't matter but what is it like
you know what i'm doing accounting all
day and I'm pissed I should be out
selling I should be out like don't put a
sales person to do an accounting job it
doesn't work like if you just signify if
you're if you're a true sales guy and
you love meeting people face-to-face and
you're just stuck in front of a computer
all day it's going to drive me nuts
right you can only force yourself to do
something for so long
and then okay you actually get
distracted or have to like pump yourself
up to go and do something where the work
should pump you up so if you find
yourself in that mode of just autopilot
just trying to look at what am i doing
right now like what's it what's the task
and then whatever wish I could be doing
right now because you'll never you'll
never build the company you want to do
if you're spending time on these
autopilot tasks this you're not gonna
happen right you never be great if
you're doing accounting stuff you put a
salesperson accounting role right and
you know Michael Jordan playing baseball
it's good to explore like you've tried
it you know that accounting is not for
you great like what are the things that
you love doing and focus on that and so
[ __ ] just like that's that I think
that would be way more effective for you
then trying to read another book or
trying to watch another video or add
another think your to-do list just
you're already in the self analyzing
mode figure out where your autopilot and
what task you're doing I didn't think
about what do you love like where do you
where did you like lose track of time
we've gone over time man I've lost track
of time because this is what I love
doing I bet i find hangouts and phone
calls all day long from the morning nap
all day long is this is the last one and
we're going over because i still have
energy because i love doing this right i
get lost in this what are the activities
that you look down and like what just
happened to the last four hours of my
time right that's where you need to add
more but that's we need to spend more
time that's where you're adding the
value yes yes i think that your your
your business will change your life will
change man right yeah i'm on pumped up i
just listened to you yeah but that's not
enough like it's great yet always get
like a shock from that with you i'll see
on a common alright like the work the
work that you love doing I hate doing I
hate doing sales I hate going out and
like Boeing and networking events and
talking to people the event that you
came up and met me and talked to me I
would never do that I would never go to
an event and go talk to somebody at the
front I really do think you're and the
snow me someone else your network is
your net worth and I i love i love
making connections and it's it's it's
helped me to get where I am
and but but hey thank you so much for
forgiving me your time yeah I I feel
like after talking to you in the past 45
minutes I did I did I I started looking
at things that I actually hadn't thought
about before um one is you know if I if
I have to outsource a task you know I
should probably outsource to not do it
myself you know like as a CEO our
co-founder you have this idea that you
want to have control of everything and
and that's a mistake sometimes I make uh
you know my my other co-founder Massoud
is also written doing some other tasks
but I need to be out there do more of
what I wanted your end and I and I
really appreciate your time and your
expertise and I learn it on today learn
the time all right now it's time to
execute yes you gotta do right not just
add to the list you gotta do excited to
hear you do oh man and build up the
Toronto businesses oh well ah awesome uh
you know and appreciate your honesty and
willingness to get you know a little
vulnerable there thank you guys for
watching the live chats been like
blowing up all day people had questions
but we're way over so again thank you
guys for watching that's the end of the
hang us for today continue to believe
and we'll see you soon